Lisa, I share your concern about climate change.
This is something that’s one of the biggest
challenges that humanity has ever faced, and
it’s something that in the next couple of
decades and centuries we’re going to have
to really band together and work together
to solve.
And when you ask a question like you did,
about “how might you solve climate change,”
it actually gives me a lot of hope because
it means that young people like you are really
starting to think about ideas about how we
could address climate change.
You said, “could you build a giant disk
and put it between the earth and the sun and
have it act as a kind of sunshade actually
cooling down the earth?”
That’s a wonderful idea.
There are some things about that that would
be quite difficult and one thing is that the
sun is actually very large, it’s much larger
than the earth, so it actually projects light
around anything that you put up there.
You’d have to put a very, very large disk
up there.
It might have to be something roughly the
size of the planet in order to shade the planet
effectively against the sun.
So that’s something that might be possible,
but it would be very expensive and difficult
to construct.
But I love the fact that you’re thinking
about it.
It does however to me sort of not address
the underlying problems with climate change.
A lot of people have ideas similar to yours
that, what if we could just block out some
of the sun’s light, would that actually
make climate change go away?
And one of the ideas people have is possibly
launching lots and lots of particles of dust
up into the atmosphere.
We observed that when there’s a volcanic
explosion and the earth naturally puts lots
and lots of dust up into the atmosphere, the
earth’s climate cools.
We observed this in the ‘90s when Mount
Pinatubo erupted and we actually had a decline,
a little bit of a notch on the global warming,
just due to this volcano putting lots and
lots of stuff up into the atmosphere.
So could we do that artificially could we
just darken our atmosphere to actually have
less sunlight get through?
The answer is yes, we probably could, but
it would be a huge effort.
A single volcano puts up many, many thousands
of tons of dust up there, so this would have
to be something continuous: lots and lots
of rockets or aircraft distributing dust across
the atmosphere.
And the thing that kind of frightens me is
that we really don't understand our atmosphere
enough to know what that sort of cooling would
do.
The atmosphere stores heat, it creates winds
and of course the air moves around, there
are storms; scientists spend a lot of time
studying how the atmosphere stores heat, how
the weather forms, and when you darken the
atmosphere I’m not sure what it would do
to our weather.
It would be a very dangerous experiment to
do if you couldn’t control it.
And the same thing with building a disk: I’m
not sure that darkening the earth is a very
good idea; it may change things like weather
patterns or even ocean currents, the winds,
all of that.
It also doesn’t get at the problem of carbon
dioxide.
Now the reason our atmosphere is getting warmer
and warmer and warmer is because we humans
are putting lots of carbon dioxide up into
the atmosphere and this acts as what we call
a greenhouse gas.
Sunlight can get through the atmosphere but
the carbon dioxide traps it and it can’t
release itself back into space so it gets
warmer and warmer over time.
Carbon dioxide doesn’t just warm the atmosphere,
it also affects our oceans.
When ocean water combines with carbon dioxide
it creates something called carbonic acid
and it makes the oceans more and more acidic
over time and this is a really big problem
for marine life.
There are things like algae, the algae in
the oceans are responsible for most of the
oxygen that we breathe, and the algae are
having trouble forming because of the higher
acid levels in the ocean.
So even if the one thing you solved was cooling
the earth down, if we continue to put more
and more carbon dioxide into our atmosphere
there will be other serious repercussions.
We could end up killing the ocean life system,
for example.
So the problem really isn’t an external
one, it’s not simply cooling the planet
putting up lots of dust or building a wonderful
shade like you suggest, the problem is really
getting at our emissions of carbon dioxide
and stopping those and stopping these dramatic
changes that we see coming.
Some of them are going to be very difficult
to stop.
I mean right now we’re observing the ice
caps at both poles of the planet, in Antarctica
and in the North Pole, melting very quickly.
That won’t stop.
Those ice caps will largely melt over many,
many centuries and the ocean levels will rise
in accordance.
I do think right now the challenge is how
are we going to deal with the changes?
We might not be able to change very many of
them at this point, we need to band together
as people make sure that we have ways to deal
with refugees—people need to leave where
they are because the oceans are rising.
There’s going to be a lot of people that
need homes, and there’s going to be a lot
of support needed for the changes in agriculture,
in fishing, in so many parts of our economy
and our lives.
There’s no easy solution.
I do love that you’re thinking about it,
and we need you to keep doing that.